yes you're talking rogan we had a good
time yes we had a good time did you did
you watch the whole thing oh man i look
you're gonna think it's goes you know i
like him we're friends and stuff like
that but i'm a big rogan fan that was
one of the best broken episodes it
really was tell me a lot you guys vibed
man you guys seemed like old buddies for
like like you you were hanging out with
like a dude from uh from the barracks
back in the day yeah he was really
engaged
i mean he just abnormally engaged i
thought what was in the cup was that
water in the cup
it was vodka committed to my heritage
you know i uh
in austin
when you went in there how long did you
think the interview was gonna last i
have no idea i mean i you you don't you
don't think from that standpoint but
literally we're both talking all of a
sudden you look at the clock i'm like oh
i'm going to be late to my flight
because they told me if i don't get to
the uh uh
the
uh
private airport by five o'clock that's
done i have to stay overnight i'm like i
got board meetings the next day so
uh i had meetings the next day uh uh
that we had to handle but yeah we made
it it was incredible the conversation
was great he's the ultimate renaissance
man today the guy is what arrows hunting
ufc
mma
you know the us open taekwondo champion
you know the guy's everywhere he doesn't
know sports and he doesn't do nfts
that's what i learned about him
doesn't do an ftc
but he's officially got an anthony
fought your rookie card that's cute
she's the hottest man in the world
he's gonna keep talking about it until
it gets up up up the uh
was it was he the same off air or was he
was he cool same guy just the same guy
man you know
the best the best people are those that
they're just the way they are no matter
what whether the camera's on or not
same guy just chill you know
strong opinions curiosity at the highest
level
great exchange great conversation and it
seemed like
you were asking him as many questions he
was asking you he's more like
pat interviews
yeah dude i mean
i'm curious i want to know what this
guy's thinking i want to know how
you know when when you think about the
most necessary people in america i got
him at the top of the list
he's forcing the conversation to be had
he is forcing you to have the
conversation think about that yeah
without a political agenda as a starter
you got a respect doesn't have that no
he's telling you hey listen guys you
disagree let's have the conversation how
many people are doing that today versus
screw you you have no clue what you're
talking about i don't ever want to talk
to you no he says come on let's talk
yeah plus he's enlightened going through
covid and the treatment that he had he
has a really interesting perspective on
that yeah it's pretty clear that uh you
said listen calling the other side an
idiot
never will convert the other side yeah i
know he's not a fan of trump he's
definitely not a fan of biden apparently
he's a big fan of joe jorgensen in front
of the show yeah all right i gotta push
back on that though for both of you guys
i do have to push back let's hear it
don't get canceled we will cancel you
well right now son on your birthday one
part one part of it that i did agree
with is that that's a learned trait you
have to learn to give your opponents
credit and i do believe at the end of
the day
you can learn how to do this you do need
it's a learned trait and i think we do
need synergy but i think also
we lived in a moment and we're still
living in a moment where people
weaponized and empathy where an entire
group of people took people's kindness
as a weakness and at some point you had
to be firm you had to be able to tell
somebody no
put your put your two-inch earrings away
in your purple hair and shut the hell up
all right you had to you had to get firm
with people and you had to be like no
this is stupid i'm not doing what you're
telling me to do anymore i've done it
i've done it i've done it i've
acquiesced enough now i'm saying no and
if you push back again i'm going to say
no firmer i think at some point they
pushed too far they took too much
advantage and now the other side had to
get nasty with them had to match that
energy now from there once there's a
mutual respect once you understand that
hey look enough's enough and i am if
you're committed to
disrupting my lifestyle i'm committed to
living my lifestyle and then the chips
far where they may and then you can have
synergy from there that that's just my
opinion i think you need to find a local
mma place to go train because i think
you have a lot of you got rage you gotta
after seven o'clock you and him should
just wrestle and fight and yeah that's
what i'm looking to do with my spare
time i saw this freaking grizzly bear
all you have to do just tell gerard
belichick sucks and it's on yeah david
parra over there to his credit
david took the challenge oh yeah that
was big time he wouldn't he wouldn't do
it a scarcity wouldn't do it i said look
a hundred dollars the three of you guys
take me down three versus one hundred
dollars each you're getting all come at
the same oh wait wait who was it david
who else david and paul paul and nancy
and adam and nancy and manchester united
no no no
i did not get involved no nancy kicked
you right in the face adam was the first
out nancy said no
and then like the kami she is waited for
david to engage and then tried to kick
my knees yeah so david to his credit at
least it's a good strategy david came
all the way in he he he went into the
cage well you got to respect that you
got to respect it i'm thinking i'm
filming some segments tomorrow i'm
trying to go out to the club this week
and have a good time the last thing i'm
doing in my spare time is wrestling this
grizzly bear by the way it could be done
with a little strategy you just have
someone sneak behind them kneel down and
you push them over i mean
it could be
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you